well it's really weird right because
like you know obviously you grew up
in a thai house or eating spice food all
your life right yeah
and you'd think i would be the same
because like my dad [ __ ] loves spicy
food like you know like the death source
that they sell here
my dad would just put that in meals
right yeah but to me i was like why are
you putting cyanide in a perfectly nice
why would you poison this meal like this
because then he would
[ __ ] serve it up to the family oh my
god and we would have to eat it that
reminds me my
uh my older brother he was growing uh
carolina reapers
yeah and um why that's a good question
because he won he liked spicy food but
yeah um
one time this was right before i moved
to japan he
he gave them to my parents and he told
them that they were like normal peppers
oh my god why would you do that
that is truly evil they're like what
happened that's a true crime story
yeah so what happened was is that they
were like oh yeah they were saying like
oh brett's been growing some uh
some peppers and he's he's given us some
right so i'm gonna put them in the
stir-fry tonight and i think oh okay
sure
i didn't know yeah that they were they
were carolina
reapers or ghost peppers one of the
other i mean they're both [ __ ]
they're both [ __ ] hot yeah
bear am i my parents do believe that
paprika is spicy i'm not joking
they'll probably my dad watches the
podcast he'll be he'll be like you're
lying connor but
yeah um and so they made me it's the way
they did the stir-fry is they make it
and they give it to me first and then
they they make it for my dad and my mom
makes it for herself last and it's like
this is like five minutes in between
so i'm i'm eating this stir-fry and i'm
like
i'm getting kind of like i'm like
this kind of hurts and i'm thinking like
oh wow
my mum what purpose did you use
he's like oh ah this is your brother he
grew them and gave them to us and i'm
like
did he say what kind of peppers they
were so no no he just said he grew them
and i'm like
look a little kick to them
because they put all of them in like
seven or eight oh my god
[ __ ] hello ghost peppers all of them
your brother's trying to kill your
parents
well my parents didn't know they thought
they were like the like they're not like
did your parents eat them yeah so so
what happened next is that uh
you know i want them i was like i was
like i really think i'm like i'm like
bear in mind i'm like
i'm like really think that you should
like go easy on the peppers on yours if
you can like
get them out a little bit i think you
should do that like no no it's fine
we've had it before we've had these
peppers
pictures taken before disaster but at
that point i was like you know what
fine let's just see what happens let's
just see what happens
let's just see how this unfolds i'm
there like literally like that that meme
of that kid at the
the vein in his forehead yeah just
eating these peppers trying to keep a
straight face like
i'm not my daddy he's he's about to eat
it he takes one spoonful and he's like
yeah wow that's really
that's really spicy
and he just like started like crying
i thought it was so funny and my mom
thought he was over exaggerating
so my mom was like i'll try it too oh my
god
and my mom starts doing the exact same
thing she starts [ __ ] a car
after like one bite they just couldn't
finish it
they just started drinking milk for like
20 minutes what are they expecting they
were just dying it was the funniest [ __ ]
i don't know
i mean if i was your parents i'd take
one lucky you'll be like oh he's
probably not making this [ __ ] up well
they
i don't i thought they thought i was
exaggerating with how much spice i could
feel
and i was texting my brother well after
i had a bite i was like what the [ __ ]
are these peppers these are
what peppers are these these and what
are these habaneros ghost peppers
carolina reaper they're like why would
you give them to my parents you know
they can't eat these
it's just bad isn't it should actually
kill mom and dad
your parents trust you they they are so
much i think from that point onwards
they just never accepted any peppers
because i saw them and i thought they're
like oh god they look like they look
like ghost peppers
some interesting shaped peppers like
this they store the thin green ones they
look like the
the big plump like the shriveled like
ones like like satan's toe
yeah it looks like the spiciest thing
you've had uh
i'd probably say habanero
really yeah i mean i mean other than the
[ __ ] like
uh death sauce that like you know wait
have you ever eaten like a
carolina reaper or like a like a ghost
pepper why would i do that oh my god we
need to do that no youtube challenge
because it'd be fun no it's no it won't
for you just build up your tolerance for
you guys
it's not that bad people on youtube just
lit trial by fire
why did i teach them that phrase you
know people on youtube when i watched it
because i think i first saw rhett and
link do it yeah
yeah 2012 and they were like
it's not that bad it's just like it is
just discomfort it's yeah
why would i willingly put myself into
discomfort which makes great content
yeah [ __ ] you got me there
who doesn't love killing themselves the
content is like monster ramen wanker
but like why would that's way worse how
did you know how did you know i'll do
anything for you yeah
youtuber that's how youtubers mind works
right you got me there
oh we're going to film it yeah you're
going to film it okay okay
the winner doesn't have to eat a
carolina reaper
dude that's going to be the hardest run
to a w in my existence
yeah right and then if it's one of us
you have to eat three and you'll do one
that's right so what's so easy so i'm
eating one either way yeah of course
if like let's say you win i mean gonna
have to eat three each yeah yeah but
that's not going to do anything to you
no
three three four three will three will
pick me up yeah
all right fine i'm i'm be high as [ __ ]
on those individuals like mesh with your
head it does it does
like i remember like the first time i
like the first time i had
i probably had like a ghost pepper or
trinidad tobago like carolina reaper the
the spice high i thought i'd heard about
it before yeah but i didn't realize it
was literally
like getting high yeah and you feel the
after effects
um for like hours afterwards because you
feel you feel this like
warm tingly glow yeah you just feel like
you did something nice and you're like
oh what's what's
like when the initial 20 minutes of pain
is over it's just like it's pretty nice
yeah i mean i i quite kind of looks very
uh unimpressed
unconvinced i mean i mean look it is
great